He's a cold-hearted snake (OOO) look in to
his eyes.
Uh-oh.
He's been lying on a rock to get warmth from
his environment.
Sup meatbags, Trace here for DNews to talk
about why you're all SO HOT.
But really, you're hot.
Have you ever thought about why?
Thermoregulation.
Science divides thermoregulation into endothermic
or ectothermic; homeothermic or poikilothermic
(poiˈkēləˌTHərmic).
Endo and ecto thermic describe an animal that
either makes it's own heat or gets it from
the environment.
Homeo and Poikilo describe whether the temperature
is constant.
A cute siamese cat is an endotherm and homeotherm,
it makes it's own heat, and maintains a constant
body temperature; most mammals and birds are
endothermic homeotherms -- what elementary
school would call warm-blooded.
Fish, amphibians, reptiles and most invertebrates
are ectothermic poikilotherms; they get heat
from the environment and let their body temperature
fluctuate -- what the youths would call cold-blooded.
But that's only part of the picture!
They make their own heat, but don't always
maintain it.
Some fish maintain a constant temperature
and create heat by swimming from cold to warmer
water, but can't generate it themselves; leatherback
turtles and lamnid sharks do this too!
All I'm saying is, it's a wider world than
the black-and-white of cold versus warm blood!
But that's not all!
Dinosaurs used to be thought of as cold-blooded
terror lizards that would obviously make AMAZING
PARK ATTRACTIONS DON'T WORRY NOTHING COULD
GO WRONG.
// But a study in Science found dinosaurs
were likely mesotherms -- they used a combination
of internal processes and environmental factors
to adjust their overall body temperature!
Plus, animals that hibernate like chipmunks
and some bats are heterothermic!
Whew.
Yeah, It gets confusing,.
The reason we simplify it to warm and cold
blooded is because temperature, which is mainly
circulated by the blood, affects things like
muscle function and brain size.
Colder muscles react slower, meaning ectothermic
animals have to behave sluggishly when the
environment is cooler.
They have no choice!
Even if a predator is around.
According to Spring and Holley's Introduction
to Zoology, with a 18 degree F (10C) change
in temperature, muscles contract three times
faster, pulling three times the power.
Knowing this, you can understand why yellowfin
tuna evolved to be poikilotherms!
Warmer muscles react better, allowing them
to keep their bodies at a slightly higher
temperature than the surrounding water; thus
they maximize their power and catch prey.
Mammals and birds range in temperature from
97 to 104F (37-40C) and that has a cost; we
have to eat to live and regulate metabolism!
Pandas spend 10 to 16 hours a day eating,
and the British Medical Journal recorded hunger
strikers who lasted 40 days without food.
But that's child's play; pythons can go a
year between meals.
So why aren't we just SLIGHTLY regulating
our temperatures like tuna?
Seems like a big waste to burn all that energy
and stay hot all the time, right?
All that heat keeps our muscles ready for
action.
Endothermic animals can almost always outrun
ectothermic animals; assuming they survive
the initial strike.
Ectothermic animals are better at that initial
attack… think a snake or fast-fish!
Insects with cold muscles can't fly, the Sphinx
Moth vibrates its muscles before takeoff to
get them warm.
Plus, cold animals may miss opportunities
to use their muscles to get all up ons and
mate!
Warm-blooded animals can mate ANYTIME.
Which… you know.
That's fun.
PLUS all that energy and heat allows for the
evolution of more complex brain structures,
which allowed me learn to talk to you right
now!
That being said, it's hot.
It's real hot.
And sometimes it's just TOO hot… or too
cold!
So animals that evolved to be homeothermic
-- maintaining temperature -- had to ALSO
evolve fur or blubber to stay warm and sweat
glands or panting to cool off.
But that's a whole other video.
Want to know why we sweat and how AWESOME
we are at it?
Check out this video Do you have
a science question you want us to answer?
YouTube gave us the comments for a reason,
so y'all could troll, but you could ALSO use
them to ask me a science question.
Maybe try that?
And please subscribe!
We're here every day for our subscribers,
and I love my job.
So from the bottom of my heart, thanks!